foreign
he got her into really competitive teams
and whatnot it seemed like he was it was
more so for him than it was for her so
she wasn't really enjoying it as much as
uh he wanted her to yeah your kid is not
a window whose sole purpose is for you
to relive your childhood
[Music]
what up how's it going this is John with
the Dr John deloney show
I hope you are doing well
this is the a marriage and parenting
mental health show
probably the best one ever
um and here's the deal
I got one goal with this show it's to
help you the listener
not feel so alone in this world that's
gone sideways
to let you know that you're probably not
nuts or if you are maybe for the first
time someone that you trust is going to
tell you yeah it's you
this show exists because I want people
to have a better life honored to have a
more peaceful marriage aren't be able to
sleep at night without medication to be
able to drink coffee in the morning
because they want to not because they
have to I want parents and kids to
reconnect I want
people who feel safe in their schools
and feel like schools are helping out
and navigate the college process I want
to walk alongside folks and so that's
why the show exists and I continue to be
so grateful for everybody who reach out
and say hey this is this is how my
marriage is different now this is how
um my interaction with my kids is
different now this is how our sex life
has improved this is how I finally got
the courage to leave my marriage after
this many years because of the abuse and
all those things
it just it it brings me such joy and so
I'm grateful for everybody who's a part
of this show continues to grow
exponentially and I'm just so grateful
um it it means all of the world to me
and but that doesn't matter what it
means all the world to folks struggling
to get through their day if you will hit
the Subscribe button if you hit the like
button the follow button
um if you will leave five star reviews
it just puts the show in front of other
people who otherwise wouldn't know we
exist and for those of you who've been
riding with us since day one thank you
so so so much we've gone from 17
listeners to millions and it's just it's
just extraordinary so thank you so so
much all right let's go out to Savannah
Georgia and talk to Sophia Sophia how
are we doing what's going on
pretty good how are you excellent
excellent what's happening all right so
I'm calling because I wanted to ask you
or get your opinion your help
um I have a 18 year old daughter who
basically has no
it she doesn't have a good relationship
with her father
um where'd he go
well he's he's around
um they I can give you a little bit of a
back story
um so him and I we were never married we
never lived together but they you know
he would always see her
um up until about 13 when she turned 13.
they had a pretty good relationship you
know uh she'd go over there every other
weekend and during the week and whatnot
um at 13 she started playing
um Sports softball to be
um
uh precise and so
um he got her into really competitive
um teams and whatnot and it seemed like
he was it was more so for him than it
was for her eventually
um so she wasn't really enjoying it as
much as uh he wanted her to
um and so she wasn't fulfilling his
dreams as much as we needed them to be
fulfilled by his daughter so ridiculous
exactly So eventually she got out of the
competitive teams and she just stuck
with high school ball in middle school
or whatnot
um after that it seemed like their
relationship just went downhill
um because he would always complain and
say you know she didn't want the
responsibility she didn't want she was
13. right
oh my gosh you are you are pushing my
buttons it is early this morning I know
it
well um
to every parent listening
you're
your kid is not a window through which
sole purpose is for you to relive your
childhood
and your kids
think about it it's another kid tossing
a ball and another kid hitting it with a
stick
are chasing us anyway all right I I can
get derailed here and it's too early to
be drinking so go ahead go ahead
Okay so
bye and um she's she's 18 now so she
just graduated high school
um and throughout the years he was he
just kind of got a little out of her
life
um little by little I think the whole
softball thing was what triggered it and
then he would just say oh well when I
call her she barely talks to me or if I
text her she just answers with you know
hi or no or you know one word answers or
whatnot
um and I remember I'd always tell him
well you know she's a teenager I don't
think she particularly wants to sit down
and have a huge conversation about life
with our dad right now or her mom for
that matter you know
um so he would always complain about
that he is an immature coward
yeah and if you've listened to the show
I don't throw that around a lot but I'm
so sick oh the only thing worse and I
get more frustrated over
I get frustrated over kids unfettered
access to social media that's number one
I get super frustrated by parents
obsession with travel Sports and forcing
their kids along and then saying it's
for them and I especially am sick
of kids
being responsible for making mom and dad
feel special and loved and that kind of
she just responds with high or whatever
it's the parents job to show up in that
relationship because they're kids
right right and men and that's what I've
always told him because he would ask me
oh well you know what do you think the
issue is and I know here's the issue I I
would tell him you know I think you're
the one who needs to show up you're the
adult
um now that she's 18 he said well you
know she's an adult now you can't use
that same excuse and I said well you
never really tried either you know and
so I guess at the end of the day what
I'm wanting to
to know is if I should tell her hey why
don't you try and have a relationship
with him just because I don't want her
feeling like what did I do for my dad
not to love me she's gonna feel that no
matter what because her dad doesn't
right so you're trying to
create a fantasy that's not real
okay I am heartbroken for you that your
daughter's dad
is such a spineless coward that he's
walked out on his daughter
I'm sorry because I know that
you love your daughter a lot and you
don't want to see her hurt like she's
going to hurt
great and she is
your dad told me she doesn't you know it
doesn't bother her it doesn't but it
does of course she has to say I know it
does she has to say that
um
jeez man I
yes she is going to miss her dad
and she is gonna find all sorts of
substitutes in life to fill that massive
massive hole in her heart
um
but he's a spineless coward
and that's all there is to it it's all
there is to it
um even the language of well she's an
adult now you can't use that yes you can
because I've seen 70 year old parents
who are abusive and who were dogmatic
and who were obsessive about this is my
religion or my rules or my I'm right
and they finally dropped that charade
nonsense and they said hey you're my kid
I love you and the kid was 38.
and I've seen healing there too but it
has to come from Mom and Dad
because they're the parent
yeah and your sweet little girl doesn't
have that
and so right
if I'm here's the deal the only thing I
can tell you here I don't have like a a
clinical study to back up what I'm going
to say I'm just going to tell you that
if I was sitting across from my daughter
and her mom had had just mysteriously
laughed and then would say things like
whenever I text her she just writes back
one one word letters so she doesn't even
like me what stupid crap like that uh by
the way I would you want to put a pin in
something you said before I get back to
it I know I'm all over the place because
it just gets me all fired up
um the whole idea that quote unquote
kids just naturally pull apart when
they're teenagers is actually not true
it's it's it's not born out in in the
scientific literature it's not real
they do it because they have to survive
there is some and I don't mean this in a
gross abusive way I I mean this in men
become terrified of their daughter's
sexuality and they don't know what to do
with it
and so they don't they're not creepers
they're not abusers they just disappear
and that child has to have somebody in a
relationship moms have a weird
interaction with their daughters at
times especially teenage daughters and
it's easier to just kind of back up I
don't want to get in the way they want
to be with their friends so we have a
generation of kids who are being raised
by their peers and we've heard the
studies that you know peers peer
influences more than parent influence
but that's because we have become wholly
unlikable people as parents we've
abdicated our responsibility to schools
and to screens and to other peers
and even even with my buddy like I was
like a youth Minister parents come up to
him and it's like hey you're going to
teach him this this and this and it's
like that's your job you're the parent
right so the parents have outsourced
everything and now kids they don't their
parents aren't trustworthy and so of
course they're going to have other
people but let me tell you something
when you meet kids who trust their
parents and whose parents are fun
likable people who also hold them
accountable I'm not talking about just
chaotic but I'm talking about who are
good solid adults it's it's incredible
to watch their kids love their parents
of course they love their boyfriend or
girlfriend and their friends but they
love their parents it's not it's not a
weird thing like it is in so many
millions of households so I'm gonna put
you want to put a pin in that if I'm you
and I'm having this conversation
um
I would sit down before my daughter goes
to college and let her know something
was wrong with that not you
and I'm I'm heartbroken and sad that Dad
chose immaturity and Dad chose
um
uh other things
but that she is not the problem that is
yeah and I've had that conversation with
her because
uh like on Father's Day or on his
birthday if she texts him or calls the
first thing he says oh you finally
remembered or oh you remembered because
it's a special day or whatever
so I'm thinking you know why would he
even do that to her
he's an immature she's a child he's a
child
yeah
and so yeah here's what you cannot do
two years Sophia you can't do this you
cannot put this burden on her
right okay
and you can tell her I'm really
heartbroken that
um you don't have a good relationship
with your dad because that's such an
important part of human development is
having a good relationship with with
your mom and your dad and you don't have
that I'm so so sorry
I think that um I think that
conversation is true and real and maybe
um woman to woman saying hey here's how
you might go looking for that
relationship out in the world don't or
here's how to do this wisely right
um because that that that leaning will
be there uh Mr Philip help fill up that
other that Gap but
oh man
um don't put the emotional regulation of
of an immature dad on an 18 year old
girl she can't carry that weight it's
not her it's not her responsibility at
some point if she chooses
and again not as an 18 year old I'm
talking about a 22 25 like she's
established she's got a job she's
figuring out life if she chooses to say
I want to be in relationship with this
guy I want to have something to do with
him I know he's immature I'm not coming
to him to fulfill my needs like I'm not
coming to him as a daughter trying to be
full and loved but I do want to know my
old man
um that's that's totally her idea and I
would 100 support that
but she would be going all it's almost
informational at that point it's almost
I want to learn about myself it's it's
self-exploration
um more than it is
um some sort of
um cathartic healing relationship
dad left her man
in every stage he's left her
and when she quit and here's here's the
The Meta when she quit performing for
him
when she could perform for him he was in
and when she could uh make him feel good
about himself uh she was in
but he didn't have the capacity to make
her feel loved and seen
and I hate that for everybody I'm sorry
but for for all the oh gosh all the
parents listening
it's not your kid's job to make you feel
loved I don't care how old they are
it's your job
it's your job to make them feel loved
and if they don't text you the right way
or they don't call you the right way or
they do call you don't start off with
passive aggressive oh so now you decide
to just answer the phone and say oh my
gosh everything in my day is better
because I get to hear your voice I'm so
glad you go
and by the way don't wait for your kids
to call be an adult
be a grown-up be a parent you call
let them tell you oh let them roll their
eyes and you keep calling and keep
calling because never let them think for
a second
I don't have a safe place to go with
with him I have a safe place to go with
her
breaks my heart breaks my heart breaks
my heart thanks for the call Sophia
we'll be right back
[Music]
I've got a word from our sponsor better
help listen I've been on both ends of
therapy in my life I've gotten it myself
and I've walked people through it and
I've seen the benefits from both sides
when someone owns their past and the
cracks in their armor but here's the
deal Getting to Know Yourself is not a
one-time event acknowledging the stories
that make you who you are can be a
lifelong process and talking through
things with the right sounding board
empowers you to change your future and
be the best version of yourself so if
you're thinking about starting therapy I
recommend better help better help
connect you with a licensed therapist
who can walk with you on that journey of
self-discovery and it's a hundred
percent online and it's designed to be
convenient flexible and work for your
schedule just fill out a quick
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and if it's not the
right fit you can switch therapists at
any time for no additional charge visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com
deloney
all right we're back let's go up to
Ashton in Jacksonville Florida what's up
Ashton
hi Dr John how are you good how are you
good thanks for taking my call of course
what's up
well I have almost like an iceberg of a
question initially it's fairly simple
but when
it just goes into so many facets of my
son in my life it just becomes more
complicated sure go for it so a quick
backstory I'm in my mid-30s I'm happily
married to my husband and we have two
children together
our son was born about 10 and a half
years ago and he was diagnosed with
cerebral palsy
he is doing amazing wow he's awesome
we were told originally his prognosis
was he might never speak clearly he
might never walk without assistance
and he's overcome all those hurdles in
these past 10 years oh it's amazing
congratulations it's so cool
thank you we we know we are blessed
absolutely we have supportive family we
have supportive church members
but it feels almost as if we live in
this in between world
because he's doing so well
a lot of people can't tell initially
that he does have special needs
but he also does so well
that
he doesn't
necessarily uh I guess lack of better
term fit in with children with special
needs
so I'm just asking for some advice on
how to
help him navigate now that he's becoming
a teenager soon
we don't want him necessarily to fit in
but have the confidence
to know who he is
and know that wow there are limitations
I mean it is a reality so there's a
there's another side to this he doesn't
fit in with
what we would traditionally think is as
a classroom with full of children with
special needs but that means he also
doesn't fit in with the kids running
around playing PE or football PE and run
around and you know like being a normal
jumping up and down so he's kind of
finding himself in no man's land right
exactly and he he started to realize
this recently and he mentioned to me the
other day that he was feeling a little
bit lonely because you know the boys
will run off the play tag and he he
can't do that but he can still play sure
so um and um if it's okay with you
um
Kelly
the producer of the show has very
personal experience with this a very
similar situation with her son and I
would love to invite her on to her
expertise her lived expertise in this is
that okay
really can I just share one more little
Factor absolutely you got it
okay so um my husband is in the military
and he's gone a lot like most military
members however when he's gone there's
no contact while he's gone okay there's
no phone calls no letters yep
and so
I really it's really just me for
five six months of the year
so that makes it a little bit more
challenging yeah in my opinion yes
um I'm going to give you a a Meta
Picture that I'm gonna unpack here but I
want Kelly to speak into some of the
very specifics with your young one okay
um okay
foreign
[Music]
it sounds like there is a fight going on
inside of you
between the way this should all look
versus the way it does
and here's how that unpacks
who who wouldn't want to be married to a
special ops guy who comes home and says
I'm going to save the world literally
can't tell you where or when but I'll be
home
and like that sounds so amazing
and then very romantic in a book that's
what I mean like in the movie when Chris
Pratt flexes and it's like oh I I I'm
like I'm Chris press looking pretty good
like I'm into it like so uh and then
also he's just gone and there's also
month four
of
um Black Ops deployment
it's really lonely
and then there is the
two kids running around and
who wants to be having a conversation
with their kid about they can and can't
do right and you're so grateful that
he's doing so good and he's beat every
prognosis
and yet we still need to have this
conversation because high schools Middle
School's gonna be tough on it man right
you see what I'm saying
and so there's there's something to be
set up for
the devastating
um you have to agree that at some point
owning the reality this is my picture
and from there from from the choice to
own reality out of that is okay here's
what we can do here's what here's the
the conversations we can have the
support networks I need but I'm going to
live out of this because with my body's
still trying to solve for this picture
that's not real it's going to be hard
it's gonna it's gonna constantly feel
like you're at war with yourself or it's
that
underlying it that burn of anxiety that
never stops that exhaustion right
because we're we're trying to make a
life happen this just isn't our reality
um so I'm gonna read Kelly on here
um Kelly tell your story about Nathan
hey Ashton how are you
good good
um so I am a few years down the road
from you I have a 17 year old and he um
is um we adopted him when he was two
he has CP as well where yours is right
side of the body ours is lower half of
the body
um he walks with a limp we've had quite
a few surgeries and years of therapy
which I'm sure you know that
um oh we live at the therapist exactly
yeah it's like you might as well just
move in with them
um yeah a lot of physical therapy
um some surgeries that were
life-changing for us and but you know
it's still this is It's the reality we
live in it's his reality he still has a
limp there's still some things happening
um there's still a lot of things he
can't do so I understand we're going
with that and
so what you say you you talk about how
he's starting to question that is he at
the point where it's like I want to play
football I want to do that I want to do
these things
yes it is you know I want to do some
more things but even more so it's
um like in PE
you know he can participate to a certain
point right and he doesn't want to be
separated from his friends and I just I
think
so he actually is highly intelligent
that was my next question so
developmentally he's fine
yes there's no emotional or intellectual
delays he actually was skipped a grade
wow
because he is so intelligent which is
wonderful but now he's with even bigger
kids right that was I was about to say
that yeah that's probably it's a
double-edged sword there so let me ask
let me ask both both moms here
um Kelly what what what is
is there a benefit to teaching him
um Sheila my wife calls it
exceptionalities that you've got some
differences
and I'm gonna teach you how to begin to
advocate for yourself both with your
friends and with the pet PE teacher and
that's going to be a part that's going
to be conversations that
you two moms will have that I won't have
with my son right right but it's just
it's it's it's teaching them to own the
reality right right we've we all we've
always been very very open about talking
about the disabilities because I've got
two kids with disabilities and about
that this is just you know your reality
and we talk we always say that the only
thing this gets you is better you know
parking at the front and better light
and you know front line at Disney which
it doesn't even get you that anymore uh
they took that away but um you know this
just gets you better parking you still
have to function in the world but it
does look different and there's
different ways you have to do things
does he have a um are you does he have
an IEP
uh no okay
we we go to a small Christian School
okay
and we chose that school because we can
speak directly with the teachers and
every year we just have a
like a document we saw at the school
with certain exceptions for him that
they will follow physical yeah I I would
tell you I hear this a lot and
I it's been my experience that often not
every time but public schools because
they have to they have to provide
resources by law
um often small private schools will roll
out of responsibilities or say well we
just don't do that or we can't help with
that when Public Schools absolutely 100
will because they have to by law and one
thing we found with very skilled workers
very skilled workers and other kids like
him
yes so that is that leans into that he
is doing so well
um we spent months we even actually had
to go through a legal process where
the city had said you know save these
services for a child who really needs it
oh my God what wow specifically wow yeah
he's he's intellectually Advanced and
we're not looking for a legal battle I'm
yeah you know we're gonna do what we
need for our son you need to reach out
to disability rights
um uh Jacksonville uh I mean disability
rights Florida because that's that's
their purpose
nonsense crap like that
um okay let me get back to like just
okay sorry are you getting me all fired
up yeah I know that's where I want to go
with that but with the issues you're
dealing with does he have a group of
friends
yes at the school he does have a group
of friends good those especially those
boys are going to become your his
lifeline
um my son had the same group of friends
from kindergarten and we moved in high
school in you know he's dealt with that
he's done it but we found out that when
I dug into those kids and you know
they're how they how that group worked
because I was I always had the fear that
are they getting left behind are they
making fun of him my son Falls a lot
that's just who he is he trips and he
falls and they just know they wait yeah
every day it's part of their world they
just wait they're like it's just Nathan
it's what he does and so those group of
boys
um I I started a lot of having those
boys around not just in school we did
things with those boys it's who we did
birthday parties with it's who we had
over
um because I knew they were gonna there
they will start to protect him from
anyone else
uh because for them they're just like no
it doesn't matter it's just you know uh
whatever your son's name is it's just
him and they don't think anything
different
and we've started having to find because
my son did that well maybe I could play
basketball and you know in your heart
that's not gonna happen
you know and so it's not going to work
well possibly that could work what are
some other options if you don't do that
and now my son plays Esports which is
basically a glorified way to play video
games
um but it's where he's found his
community
it's where he's found as people and he
loves it and so relying heavily on those
boys and their families getting to know
their families and there are jokes that
my son will make about his disability
with his friends that I will tell you
make me cringe
but it's how he thinks they're funny
he's okay with it I always say you know
you just make sure you're okay with it
oh I think it's hilarious because it's
just who I am Mom it's not I'm not
hiding anything
my son's comedian too he yeah like if he
can't pick something up he'll be like oh
right he's not working today yeah and
you know my son does some DJ stuff and
he wanted to be be DJ crippled at one
point I was like no we're not gonna do
that we're gonna call a big no on that
but I've we've always with Nathan just
kind of let him lead
the conversation
um because
let him lead how he wanted to do it but
put plenty of options you know here's
the options and if you want to play
basketball buddy great you never know
you might find that coach that'll let
him do it but uh the way he's he sees a
counselor his counselor told me
something that really helped
let
we let us as the parents always be the
yes let the coach or the whoever be the
bad guy
if you want to play basketball bud great
let's talk to the coach
or if you want to play football and then
you get to hug them and hold them when
they cry because you know it's not going
to happen but you're the one that says
great I'm behind you if that's what you
want to do
but then when you know it's not going to
happen all right well let's look at
chess or
acting or whatever but that you that was
very helpful because
I my husband and I want to raise him as
he's just a person right he's Jinx you
know this this isn't it's a part of his
life but it's not it's not who they are
it's just you know it's just like I have
brown hair and it's important I always
encourage him I and I wasn't sure now
that if he's getting older I should say
no because I've just been doing what you
read recommended giving other options
and saying okay well we'll see what look
into it
and as he got into Middle School more we
had well why don't you go talk to the
coach kind of making him do it a little
more and then when he was like mom he
said you know that he doesn't think
it'll work okay well do you have any
interest in being the manager no okay
well then you know what when you cry
that's what I that's where I come in and
by the way for for parents that don't
have kids with special needs
um my sister was is a savant she's a
brilliant she's an academic decathlon
team my little brother missed like two
questions on the ACT and then there was
me the football player in the middle
right so my parents had to they had to
have different conversations every kid
is different that's right and so I think
it's backing out of your expectations
and dreams and wishes for this one and
saying who is this human being before me
and what special contribution can this
kid make to the world and what
limitations is this person going to have
and every kid's gonna have them children
with special needs are going to have
more pronounced ones that we can all see
but it but it's it's you can't clear
every obstacle right you just can't
because you're not you know he's gonna
have to live a life and you can just you
know you know we've told Nathan before I
can't clear this obstacle but I'll help
you figure out a way around it
and you know what can I I do to help you
and if you need me to advocate for you
if you need whatever I'll do it but it's
not just going to go away because it's
just part of the world they have to live
in the world still
but yeah absolutely
um as a child as a parent with a child's
special needs um
I've seen all sorts of children in a
therapy if we go to the doctors and I
see so many families who have it
much more challenging and heartbreaking
than us
and
I struggle with feeling
almost
guilty using Services sometimes stop
stop with that get that out of here
right now don't ever feel guilty yeah
Felicia with that yeah that's done you
get you cannot compare tragedy right you
can't compare
um pain you can't compare individual
circumstances
your reality is your reality there are
plenty of services you need them for
it's not some zero yeah there's not just
a you know a pie and this is all we get
you know there's only so many services
you have as much right to those Services
because you're advocating for your child
so yeah you got to let that one go
because because we've just we've we've
gotten our child everything that had
been recommended it's just we've
you know had to go through several
locations to try and find someone who
would give it to us without us having to
fight them right and that's that's
because we live in a messy ugly and
sometimes you will have to fight them
yeah and that's okay because you there
are Services I hate to use the word
entitled but that you have the right to
but don't ever feel guilty and I mean
like there's times with you know like
hey the handicapped parking spot there's
one four down from that that we could
take and Nathan's like I'm fine walking
that Mom I can do it okay great we'll do
that you know and not take up that spot
in case somebody needs it but yeah
you've got to let that that guilt go yes
there are
again we don't compare tragedies there's
different versions everybody's fighting
their own battle so yeah that you're
doing what you got to do for your boy
okay smile smile big smile big and and
for whatever it's worth
um I've I've taught at the University
level at the highest level with doctoral
students and I've taught
um law students so I've been in across
the board here right or I would say I
taught law students serve law students
um
hahaha
the opportunities for your child are
going to look different but the the
world is is open for them right and so
let that let that little boy be who he's
gonna be and be the be the fuel in his
jet pack not the GPS system telling him
where he's gonna go does that make sense
yes yeah two other things hold on I want
to say real quick
um
not a bad idea maybe to start a
counselor we started a counselor with
our son about maybe 12 10 12. because
there's going to be some anchor issues
and there's going to be some things he
doesn't want to talk to you about
so we actually just started Council
perfect for him that is I wanted to find
a man who and that's what we are
be there that's what we did and it was
great and it's been in Nathan's 17 and
he still goes once a month and he loves
it so that's a great thing to put in
place and then
learn to be the sounding board when he
comes home and says mom it really sucked
today because they played basketball and
I couldn't do it you can't fix that
remember that you can't fix it but you
can sit there and go wow that must have
really hurt
tell me tell me about it
can I hug you yeah you want a hug or you
know whatever you can't fix them all and
sometimes you just have to sit there and
go I'm sorry
yeah but I I'm sorry that really does
suck
and can I challenge you and husband
yes
um this is easier for me to say because
it just doesn't apply to me at this
moment in my life
I would love to challenge your husband
too every week he's home write a letter
and put it in an envelope that's undated
so that every week he's gone
your two kids get a letter from Dad
tell them how much he loves them how
special they are how
um like an exciting memory he might have
that's not um that he can that he could
share a piece of or something but that
they are getting something
um some sort of communication some sort
of reach out and five years from now ten
years from now 25 years from now
the effort the kids will will understand
what links their dad went to
um to make them feel special and seen
and loved even when he was out uh
fighting evil in the dark
I think that'd be a cool thing
that's a great idea we're definitely
gonna
Implement that
that won't be fun for him I know but uh
man I think the I think the gifts long
Downstream to your kids would be magical
but all in all um Kelly thank you so
much for your wisdom and insight there
uh
thank you for being a great mom Ashton
thank you for being a great mom and
congrats to your son for just continuing
to defy the odds
um
I love the idea of every parent sitting
back and asking themselves not what can
I make my kid do
what what what is my kid capable of
who is this person in front of me
were they into what do they love what
are the things we need to Rally around
them right so if your kid is all into
theater and choir that's incredible
you're gonna have to be help with with
movement with I think I want you to play
soccer I want you to we're going to go
outside and go for walks together
because movement's important and if your
kid is just jocked 2000 let's go crush
them in cool
um I want you to take uh piano or violin
too like I'm it's it's our job to round
out our kids
but it's not our job to say you will end
up here
I'm telling you
can't count the conversations lots of
them
kids in their fourth year of grad school
or finishing up a PhD or finishing up an
undergrad degree
saying I absolutely hate my life and I'm
only doing this because Mom and Dad said
this is what you're right they they they
force me into a path
um
moms and dads love our kids and Ashton's
just setting a great example for a
little one thank you so much for the
call Ashton we wish you guys the best
holidays ever help and thank you
and your husband for your service
and um for all those that are out on Ops
that none of us know about except for
the husbands and wives sitting at home
with their jaw clinched we're grateful
for you we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here
I fell through a glitch in The Matrix
this is my job I get to have this show
do this show walk alongside each one of
you as a career this is what I do and I
have a blast doing it and me and the
team were so thankful for all of you for
being a part of our show whether you're
one of the original 17 or you're one of
the millions that's come since then we
are so grateful for you and we want to
put together the best possible show that
we can so if you're one of The Originals
or if you're brand new we want your
feedback tell us what you love about the
show what you hate about the show what
you'd like to see more of what you like
to hear more of and what you want us to
never do again you can email us at
askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's ask
John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show Rocco
all right let's go out to uh Charlie in
Kansas City Missouri wood is up Charlie
hey John how's it going partying man
what are you up to
oh just working very cool dude what's up
um so it's kind of a complicated
question but also not you know doesn't
seem like a huge deal but it's really
been bothering me okay bring it on
so
uh recently I I just got engaged to my
fiance and uh her parents have
generously gifted us
um 10 acres to build a house on is it is
that 10 acres connected to a family
place
so yeah there's 30 I mean it's 40 total
but no one lives here so
um but it's theirs
yes
um so you know they just used it
recreationally over the past you know
whenever they bought it 20 years ago
um and you know didn't do much upkeep
just harder to farm the fields and then
you know Road four wheelers or dirt
bikes or whatever
um so over the past year and a half two
years
we spend a lot of time and money um talk
directly into your phone Charlie
um there you go is it better much better
yeah
okay so over the past you know year and
a half two years we've spent a lot of
time and money fixing it up you know
putting in a road building
you know basically the utilities for it
so that it's usable are you all already
living together
uh yes okay I was wondering why you were
fixing up your girlfriend's parents
place but okay all right yeah it's I
mean we've been dating for a very long
time so okay all right um and we should
have been engaged probably before we did
but that's besides the point
um took me a while to get around to it
um
so the problem comes with my fiance's
dad and it's not that big of a problem
and he's a wonderful guy to be around
except for when it comes to working out
at this you know this place we're
building a house
um
I I have very high standards
um you know with my stuff I like to keep
it nice and and keep it looking good and
it seems like every time he comes out
here to help
uh you know things get ruined you know
roads get trashed you know
stuff gets mowed that shouldn't be mowed
um you know that type of stuff and I you
know it makes me angry so you know kind
of like you say in your your podcast
when you get angry walk away and I try
and do that you know so that way
I don't
you know I don't know the right word for
it but it
how much of the frustration here of your
anger is
because you're not clear
do you have a vision for this place and
then he comes to help so I when I moved
to my new place out here I I live on
some Acres out here I mowed my neighbors
I I live next to an elderly neighbor I
mowed their field for them it took me
four hours I was trying to be a good
neighbor show this new person how great
and I mowed their hay field down
like yeah I I totally screwed up dude
my wife came home and she's like she
grew up out on acreage too and she's
like what have you done and I was like
I'm a great neighbor and she was like no
no you're not but I didn't know I didn't
know so is there a Clarity issue or is
he just like a good loving
disaster
and that's part of it whenever we bring
something up you know he apologizes and
says he won't do it again and then the
next time he's out here something
happens so at what point do you quit
inviting him out
but the thing is you know it's his place
as well that's the problem but he's
doing it all out of the goodness of his
heart
you know
um so it's it's I don't know
here's the magic line you got to choose
guilt over resentment
because you're going to get dangerously
close to getting sick of the side of
this guy
well I that's the thing I mean he's
wonderful to be around elsewhere I love
seeing him but then when he comes out
here it's like oh no yes and so
choosing guilt over resentment meaning
I'm gonna have to choose the guilt I'm
gonna feel by telling him hey I want to
be like I want to learn how to do all
this stuff and so I'm asking you to not
help with this property anymore
with the fencing we want to build with
the House Clearing with the field
clearing whatever's going on I want to
do this work myself
or I want to go through the bid process
and I'm so grateful for your heart but I
want to do this and you're going to feel
really guilty and he might feel hurt
and he might even say I just gave you 10
acres you can't tell me what's it and
then the other option you have is I'm
not going to take 10 acres adjacent to
Family Farms because they're always
going to think it's kind of ours
yeah or I'm gonna buy the whole thing
I'll buy the whole P I'll buy all 40
acres from you and it's just mine
yeah well that's what I mean we kind of
talked about
um but I mean that's the thing he they
say you know we can do with it exactly
how we want you know we've maintained
all of it we mow all of it we you know
do all the stuff for all of it and then
y'all have any kids
no not yet when you when y'all have kids
you'll realize oh that's not what they
that's not what they mean
yeah like yeah of course you can do
whatever you want to with it except not
really because it's kind of still mine
because I gave it to you
so what is your what does your fiance
think about this
she thinks you're being ridiculous
no she agrees
um why won't she tell her dad hey dad
would you stop doing this
well if there's communication problems
there correct so um uh here's what's
about to happen if it hasn't already
you're going to start getting your
frustration at him is going to start
bleeding off on her
that is not the case I mean I it's not
there but I'm telling you it's coming
I'm telling you it's coming
um
so how do I
I mean it's not necessarily my place to
you know tell him what to do so like how
how do we go about this I mean it's your
place to say hey please stop coming on
my property
uh I mean it is your place
unless he gave it to her and it's not
technically yours yet
um
well and and she agrees that we don't we
want him to come out and have fun you
know ride dirt bikes whatever just
please stop working you know stuff Have
you ever sat down with a with a with a
I I don't know like a piece of graph
paper or a map and said here's our Dream
for this
and here's what we want to do and here's
what we're not going to do anymore you
ever done that
um what do you mean meaning have you
ever sat down with him and said hey
these 10 acres here's what our plan is
we're going to put a pond over here
we're gonna have grazing over here we
want to raise chickens over here and so
we're not going to mow this area at all
anymore
um this area over here I want to hire a
company to come in and do some
professional Pond work
um I know you can probably do that I
could probably do that but I want to
hire this out and I want to learn how
the GC process works how the general
contracting process works and what it's
like to do I'm going to learn all this
stuff it's going to cost money it's
gonna take time but I want to learn how
to do it over here I'm building a
chicken coop if you could help me with
that that would be amazing right and so
what you're doing is clear as kind
you're being very direct on and then if
he goes and mows a field down that
you've sat down and said hey we're
preserving this then you can say hey man
we talked about this then it's a
violation right now it's just a guy
trying to help and it's like hey I got
it dude he doesn't know what I got it
means and he sees that you're busy and
he he wants to be a good father-in-law
you see what I'm saying it just kind of
gets messy because there's no clarity
yeah
so sit down and tell them how we
actually feel
um well and I think I think it's before
how you actually feel I think it's
here's what our Our intention is with
this 10 acres here's our plan and here's
how I want to see this thing play out
here's how me and my my fiance soon to
be wife plan on doing this stuff and
then it's just it's just very clear for
him you don't have to sit him down and
be like and I'm really pissed off that
you did it like this and like this it's
less about that and more about here's
our intentions for this if he violates
those basically you're doing is you're
giving it boundaries if you violate
those boundaries now we got another
conversation to have
see but that's kind of I mean we've
already
every time something happens we ask him
to not do that then you know something
else happens so I mean so is he doing
the same thing over and over
uh I mean not really
um
it's but it's just give me an example of
something he's just blown
uh we planted a bunch of trees and you
know they got Bush hogged down but
they're not like they're five foot trees
you know how can you you miss those or
you know uh We've installed a you know
or a quarter mile road
um and then he goes and drives a you
know a big skid loader on it and tears
it up you know ruts it up and all kinds
of stuff by not you know by going too
fast or you know turning too quickly
which you know it takes me 15 minutes to
go over there and smooth it back out
it's not a huge deal but it's it's
it it's just the premise of it I don't
go over to their house and run up their
yard right so what you just gave me is
also
um
I hesitate too but I call that a
character issue
I I had somebody come and absolutely
trashed my yard recently a vendor came
and just rotted it up and they wrote me
a check for it
because they were taking care of they
were taking care of their business it
tells me if he's gonna come put huge
divots and not realize that he's just
completely rutted up your field or right
up your driveway and he's not doesn't
say hey man I'm gonna take care of that
I'm gonna come get it fixed up that's a
character issue right that's a sit down
and say hey man when you came over and
trashed this it or really made this
difficult this that was hard that was
hard for us I don't have time to come
back and fix this stuff up I'm really
grateful for your help but all
ultimately here's the deal you're trying
to piecemeal this what about this what
about this what about this and in your
head
how in the world can you go bush hog
down five foot trees that's insane
I'll tell you it's just a city guy I
mean it sounds insane but I I can see
myself doing that just trying to be
really helpful so it's really helpful
for a guy like me who loves to help who
loves being outside to have some clarity
over what's right and what's not
that's number one being super clear the
second thing is being direct choosing
guilt over resentment I want to be the
person who does this so would you please
stop mowing my yard at all please don't
do any bush hogging on the yard please
don't be on the on the driveway that we
just had redone I'm working here's my
picture here's what I'm trying to do
here
and he might get his feelings hurt he
might feel guilty but if you feel
comfortable saying hey this happened and
this happened and this happened here's
what I want to do I just want to stop
all the work on the place and I want me
and fiance to work on it and it might
also be really important for her since
you're not even married yet
um for her to sit down with her dad
and say Hey Dad we want to do this thing
together just us two just grind it out
ourselves
um which we need you to stop doing work
on the place and we want to own what
happens from here if you want to have a
contest see who's who's acreage acreage
looks nicer cool we can do that but
um otherwise I'm telling you it might
not be bleeding over now but you're
gonna start getting frustrated with your
wife because it's her dad and you're
gonna start getting frustrated with
yourself because because the clarity or
this that choose guilt over resentment
every single time and dude none of this
is easy don't you hear me say this is
easy at all I got a great father-in-law
love talking to him he's a great guy
just at my house
this would be a hard I'm just imagining
this would be a hard conversation for me
to have with him anybody trying to help
but I still have to have the
conversation still have to still have to
make it happen thank you so much for the
call we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show
from the great Tom Petty song is I Won't
Back Down it was like this I Won't Back
Down
you can stand me up at the gates of hell
but I won't back down I'll Stand My
Ground I won't be turned around I'll
keep this world from dragging me down
Gonna Stand My Ground hey baby there's
ain't no easy way out
I'm Gonna Stand My Ground And I Won't
Back Down
the great Tom Petty love you guys see
you soon thank you
[Music]